Hello, everyone. Thank you so much for coming here to think about
technologies from the National Cancer Institute.
My name is Michelle Berny-Lang, and I'm a program director from the
NCI, and pleased to have you here with us today.
So I think it's clear at this meeting and the research that we
see-- oh, no disclosures, we're government employees-- that
technologies are really advancing and underpinning
everything that we're doing in cancer research.
I don't think I've been to a session today where there hasn't been a focus
on AI, or a new modality for analyzing
cancer, or some technical component for clinical trials.
And this really holds true into how we advance the mission of
NCI, really working to advance scientific knowledge to improve
lives. And if you look across the entire spectrum of research
that we're supporting, technology is everywhere.
From the discovery science with the new modalities being
developed to look at cells at a single-cell level
over time as they evolve, to integrate data across different
modalities. If you think about prevention or early treatment
with the new cancer vaccines, or for early
diagnostics or prognostics with liquid biopsies
and extrachromosomal DNA, and how we can better analyze that data.
Moving all the way up to survivorship, where patients might wear
Fitbits or wearables to get a sense of their activity level.
So it really is a huge component of what we do at NCI,
and it's really a tremendous area of investment as well.
So this data is from the most recent year, looking at the top 10
institutes and centers and the investments that they have made in
biotechnology projects. I was slightly pained to see this,
that NCI came in as number two. It's often been number one, with
allergy and infectious disease a bit higher this year.
But as you can see, NCI is making huge investments.
This is over a $1.5 billion investment
into projects that are focused on biotechnologies or
use those technologies to advance some of their aims.
And the way that these technologies are supported are very vast and
broad. Individuals may come in with their standard R01s,
maybe through a contract. I'll talk through quickly some focused
scientific programs, and then the real meat of what we'll go into
today are technology-centric programs.
So to get your technology supported at NCI, there are a wide
variety of programs and a wide variety of areas of
interest. With the recent reauthorization, the
SBIR and STTR program has opportunities to help you
translate your technology through a small business.
There are partnerships with industry to help move the
translation from this early concept to being used in its
chosen setting. Bioengineering grants that really span a
broad gamut of technologies, working to bring integrative
approaches and to bring teams together to solve problems in
cancer.
There is nanotechnology. There are development of
assays and biomarkers. And quite new to
NIH, if you're looking for areas that we're thinking about, that we're
focusing on, these highlighted topics will give you some ideas.
And NCI has recently signed on to several with a technology focus,
quantum informatic technologies, research into
chatbots, and ways to
model complex biological systems.
And these are just the tip of the iceberg.
More ways that we really want to help you push your technologies forward.
But our focus for today will be on two of the longest-standing technology
programs at the NCI.
So next up, we're going to have Kelly Crotty from the NCI present
on the Innovative Molecular Analysis Technologies program, the
IMAT program. I'll share the Informatics Technology for
Cancer Research program, ITCR. And then after each of
those, we'll allow brief time just for general questions on those
programs. And then we're really pleased to be joined by two
members of the research community representing both of those
programs, Mary Goldran from University of California, Santa Cruz,
and Andrew Adey from Oregon Health & Science University.
They'll be joined by Kelly Crotty for a brief panel to give their
perspectives on how we are evolving technologies over
time and in response to cancer research needs.
And then we hope that you join us in a discussion and questions to
round it out. So with that, I will have our first speaker take
the stage,
Kelly.
All right. Hello. So I'm here to talk about the Innovative Molecular Analysis
Technologies program, or IMAT. So the mission
of the IMAT program is to catalyze multidisciplinary development of new
technologies that will allow us to grapple with the complexity of cancer
biology and create new possibilities in the fight against
cancer. And IMAT supports a diverse array of technology types,
from new sequencing technologies, proteomics methods,
biomarker detection assays, biospecimen science tools,
imaging tools or microscopy platforms, new ways to model cancer,
synthetic biology systems, immuno-oncology approaches.
There are a couple of very specific technology types that are out of
scope for IMAT, because they're being supported elsewhere, such as
informatics tools, and we're going to hear about the ITCR program soon.
But IMAT is really interested in supporting the development of new
technical capabilities that would be broadly useful for cancer
researchSo here we have the technology development pipeline,
where we start with kind of a raw concept or idea that goes all the way through
dissemination of a new working technology.
And we support technology development in this program with two mechanisms, the
R61 for very early stage, proof of concept
projects, and the R33 for more advanced development.
And you don't need to get the R61 to then compete for the R33.
You can come into this program and apply for whichever mechanism
best suits your stage in technology development.
So the R61, this early-stage mechanism, has a budget limit of
$150,000 direct costs per year for up to three years.
Again, these are for the technical proof of principle experiments.
There's a very high bar for innovation, and we consider this a high-risk,
high-reward program.
Similar to an R21, a mechanism you might be more familiar with, there's no
preliminary data required for the R61, although it's accepted if
available. And there should really be a question of feasibility, right?
This is a high-risk, high-reward mechanism.
If you have a low-risk, high-reward project, there's probably a
different mechanism that's better suited for you, or you could compete for a
standard R01 or R21 that goes to a standing study
section. But this program is really built to support things that are not
being supported in other mechanisms.
The R33 is for more advanced development with a budget limit of $300,000 a year for
up to three years for improvements, optimizations, technical
validation of methods that have the preliminary data to demonstrate
feasibility and need further improvements to be ready for broad
adoption. And so those considerations for broad adoption start to come
into play for this R33 phase.
Some tips for building a strong application is to start by
identifying a critical gap in currently available methods.
We can't do this type of research because the technology doesn't
exist. And then describe how your proposed technology is
going to fill that gap. Because this is a high-risk, high-reward program,
there are always questions is, why has no one done this before?
How are you going to succeed here when others have failed to build this
kind of technology? Are there breakthroughs in tangentially related fields
that now make this sort of thing possible?
Do you have a specific expertise that makes you have a unique
perspective that allows you to approach this problem in a different way?
And does the potential impact justify the risk? Right?
This is high risk, high reward. You need to show us what is that
reward that makes us want to take this risk.
And have you mitigated those risks?
So we do have a risk tolerance in this program, but we want to know that you're
going into the project with your eyes open, that you know where the risks are, and
you're prepared to address any of those challenges.
Another question is: Do you understand the needs of the end users?
Developing a new technology that has better capabilities than what currently
exists isn't going to be impactful unless someone is really
wanting those capabilities. It's not just building something better, but are you
building something useful?
And thinking about broader adoption, particularly if you're in that R33 phase,
would others be interested in using this method, and would others be able
to use this method? Have you considered the existing
infrastructure of the lab that might be your end user?
Do you understand the workflow that this new technology might be integrated into,
and the types of data that they have the infrastructure to analyze?
And last, technologies can be used in lots of different ways.
But in this application, you should really focus on the most
impactful cancer-relevant use case for your
validation experiments.
The IMAP program also requires that all applications include
quantitative performance measures.
This is the target of performance that you hope to achieve over the course of your
aims. It's very specific to the exact technology that you're proposing, but
it could be any quantitative metric: sensitivity, specificity, resolution,
yield, throughput, cost. And it needs to include the numerical target,
not just that you're proposing a new technology that will be faster, but putting
in that number. "I'm going to reduce assay time from X days to Y hours."
This is a great place to address any potential risks.
So if the reviewers might be concerned that you're going to have a really high
false negative rate, then you're going to propose to test the false
negative rate and set some sort of go, no-go criteria that you're not
going to move on until you've gotten that rate below a certain number
because that's what number would make this technology useful.
And it's really important to put these performance measures in the context
of the existing technologies. So having some sort of table where you have
your technology versus the gold standard or other currently available
technologies. And your technology doesn't have to be superior to
what's currently available in every single way, but you need to identify the
certain areas where it will outperform the competitors and then
justify why that's important.
All of these applications are reviewed by special emphasis panels, so those
panels are really focused on these technology development grants.
And there are a couple of things that I hear a lot in these panels that can sort of
kill an otherwise promising application.
The first is they might say, "This is a cool idea, super creative, super
innovative, but I just don't see why we need this in cancer research
specifically." So technologies can be broadly enabling, but
this is an NCI opportunity, so you really need to tie it back to a
challenge or a problem in cancer research.
The proposed aims don't match the gap they've identified.
So if you think that there's a challenge in clinical diagnostics
and you're going to solve that challenge, but all of your experiments are
designed around use in a basic research lab, there's kind of this
disconnect. And maybe use in a basic research lab is a steppingstone
to the ultimate goal of being more clinically relevant, but then you need to
argue that. That in this application, we're going to show proof of concept in
this setting, and here is my plan to get it to
addressing this gap that I've identified.
They say the tool will be impactful for this reason, but they don't include
performance measures for that. If you're saying that currently available
technologies are not fast enough, and we need a faster technology,
are you going to measure how fast this is in order to show to the
reviewers, "Look how impactful this will be, that I'm going to reduce
assay time by this amount, and that will be useful for this
reason." They haven't acknowledged other efforts in the area
or compared it to alternative technologies.
It's really important to put those performance measures in the context of what's
currently available, but also think about those performance measures are your
target of performance three years from now.
So are there other people that are also trying to do something in this area, and
how is your technology going to compete in three years from
now? And you can't always predict that, but knowing what's going
on and saying, "I think they may fail for these reasons, and
I'm going to succeed because I have this approach," or saying, "Their
technology will be useful for this use case, but I'm building mine
very specifically for this application." And just acknowledging that you
know what's going on in the field.
And last, the most innovative part has already been done.
What they propose now is incremental.
I especially see this a lot when there's a mismatch.
Somebody applied to the R61 when they really should have applied for the
R33. Because that R61 mechanism has a very high bar for
innovation, and if somebody uses the word incremental when
describing your project, it can be a real killer.
So we currently have forecasts out for the IMAT funding opportunities.
We're hoping for the new opportunities to be published very soon.
But if you have a specific idea for a project that might be relevant for the
program, feel free to reach out to me, send me a specific aims page.
I'll set up a video call. But right now, I'm happy to take any questions about
this program in general. Thank you.
Hey, Kelly. Thanks for that presentation.
I was wondering specifically about demonstrating
potential impact of a new technology, and especially if it is high risk,
high reward.
Other than just take my word for it, this is important, what concrete
ways can we actually incorporate that into an application?
Yeah, that's a great question.
And some of it
comes with knowing who your end user would be, right?
And so getting a letter of support from somebody who may be
well-known in the field,
who might say, "If this person built this technology, I would want
to use it," to kind of back up your claim can be important.
But also kind of citing some of the literature and saying, "Somebody did this
really interesting study, but they weren't able to answer this
question because their technology had these limitations." And that
can be some of what you can talk about to demonstrate the potential
significance of the method.
And that's especially important for things that are going to be used in basic
research, I think, where you don't have maybe clinical numbers or
something like that to back it up. But the usefulness for basic research into
cancer biology.
All right. I'm happy to turn it over for the ITCR program now.
Oh, unless we have another question. Yeah.
Are the prior R61 required for a new
R33? For example, you filed
some data, can I go for R33 directly without R61?
Yes, absolutely. So we want you to pick the grant mechanism that works best
for your project at your stage of development.
So you already have feasibility data and you're ready for that R33,
you can go straight there.
All right. Thank you.
Hello again. Kelly really cued that up nicely with the Wet Lab
Technology program, and I'll speak to our complementary
data-centric program, the Informatics Technology for
Cancer Research.
Here we go.
So really, even before these big, broad-scale
molecular characterization efforts like TCGA, the
pace of cancer research data had been rapidly accelerating.
We're on an even greater trajectory now, and that really necessitates
the need for informatics tools that can harness that data
and use it for the best possible knowledge.
And so that's really... Oh, wrong way.
That's where the ITCR program came in.
It was established in 2013 with a mission to
promote research-driven informatics technologies
across their development life cycle, and I'll talk through that in a
second, to address priority needs in cancer
research. And so these are tools and resources that may
support the acquisition, the analysis, the visualization,
the integration of data across the spectrum of cancer
research, approaches for cancer biology and treatment and
diagnosis, for prevention and epidemiology as
well. And the technologies are quite broad.
I'll give you some categories, but these are not going to be inclusive
from what we've supported so far. And I hope when you see these categories, you
see things that are missing, things that are new needs, new tools that we
need. So there are a variety of infrastructure and
method resources and tools, and so these you may be able to bring
in, collect together data, visualize large data sets like
genomics, and bring in other informatics tools.
There are ways to share and develop network biology
pathways.
There are a variety of resources that help to focus in on molecular
features, a variety of genomics tools,
ways to dig into functional proteomics, ways to
help consider epigenetics across different tumor tissues,
and a lot of these are moving to a single cell to a spatial
level.
And a bit of a catch-all category here with clinical and imaging
immunotherapy tools that help us understand the repertoire
of epitopes and neoantigens. There are clinical
informatics tools to make use of and get
unstructured data, and then a variety of tools
to support imaging, both to better understand
imaging and to turn that into clinical impact.
And for all of these, the underlying feature, and this is very much
like IMAT, they have to be tied and really driving a
key need in cancer research. So, looking at
this across the spectrum of cancer research, there are
tools to better understand cancer.
So, if you're looking for a new cancer biology project,
a way to look and see which patient-derived models are available for you.
For cancer early detection and diagnosis, the
ability to help how you can look at pathology images and
understand where a lesion may be, and then the ability to
support treatment decisions, how to interpret and
crowdsource and better understand what different genetic variants mean.
And so, the way these are supported is through funding
opportunities that are forthcoming, we hope to have them published in
the spring, that operate across the life cycle of tool
development. So, earlier, we're going to build and
prototype this tool at the earlier stage, that U01
stage.
Once they are built, the opportunity to really
enhance and expand and help to demonstrate and disseminate the
capabilities of that tool with a U24 for advanced
development. And then for tools that are widely used, really
becoming pillars in the cancer research community, are sustainment
tools to keep those relevant, to keep them up to date, and keep them
usable by the community. And each of those have a different cost and a
different time associated with them as you move throughout the pipeline.
And we previously had an earlier stage opportunity for those
high-risk, novel development of algorithms.
And if that's where your tool is, let us know, and we're happy to let you know
where that might fit within a suite of NIH opportunities.
So, there are some unique features to this program that are helpful to keep in
mind, and one key takeaway is that the
tool really has to be driven by and supportive of a
critical need in cancer research.
So, they are aiding hypothesis-driven research.
They're helping to advance translational or clinical research.
These are tools that we want to have more broadly available, so they have to be
under an open source license and available for use by the
biomedical research and nonprofit community.
And these are not just tools that we want a single lab or the lab next
door to use. We really want them to be able to be resources
and tools across the broader spectrum of cancer research.
And so applicants have to really think about how they're going to
engage with potential end users, who those end users may
be, who else they could be, and how they're going to take their
feedback and their input to develop the tool into something that really
meets those needs. And to keep making sure that that
gap is bridged between having an easy-to-use tool and someone
that can put it into their hands, teams are working to promote their
tools and develop ways with documentation and training and
outreach to help them get into the right hands.
So, looking into these stages in a bit more detail, that
U01, you want to build something that fits this critical
need, or you're going to make really significant adaptations to a
tool. And so, you're prototyping, you're moving it into that
initial dissemination. And the focus is really on
novelty. This is something that is fulfilling a unique
capability that we just don't have another tool to do, or that
this is really an improvement from the existing tools that we
have.
For the U24,
advanced development, you have that tool in hand, and you want to further
develop it, make it more useful, help to get it into
additional hands. And so the focus is still on this
unique niche that it fills within the cancer data ecosystem
and what unique advantages it offers compared to
other tools, and then really moving to get it into the hands of
users, understanding what they need and how the tool can
be developed to accomplish that.
And then for these must-have tools within the research
continuum, the sustainment is for a tool that already has
broad impact and broad adoption, but you can't just keep it
static. We want you to come in and make sure it's up to date, that it's
usable, that it's evolving as the needs and the data
types and the resources in cancer change.
So, to think about your application, that same key takeaway,
you really want to consider what is a gap, something
that we're missing, something that we can't do in cancer research that
limits our progress or limits what we could be doing, and then
really describe and propose a technology that will allow
you to fill that gap. And so, technologies should meet
that novelty, but should also be able to have broader
capabilities so they can work with a variety of users and
have a range of ways that they can support cancer
research needs. And again, really focusing on those end
users and how you will engage with them to ensure they can
best use the tool and ensure the tool best meets their
needs.If you do need data to
validate your tool, I just want to put here that there is a limitation on how
much budget you can use for that validation.
And really, the most important thing that you can do is reach out
to us. I support this program together with Kelly Crotty, so we're both
here today. So reach out to us. We can help you understand
where your technology is within that development pipeline and
where it could fit within the program or with other opportunities at
NCI.
And I'm going to just flash an overwhelming slide
here to let you know that you've probably heard of or
used a tool or resource that has been supported by
ITCR. I heard in the plenaries today, one of
ITCR's supported resources, DepMap, was called out.
Maybe you've used Galaxy, maybe you've used CIViC,
Bioconductor. These are some really long-standing tools that support
cancer research. And if you aren't using any of these, I really encourage
you to use that QR code and take a look and see how they may be
able to advance your cancer research.
So I'll leave you with this slide here.
There's another code that will bring you to information about the program and
where we'll update you as soon as the funding opportunities go
live. But I am happy to take questions now or in
the discussion period later.
Okay. Maybe you're saving them all up for the discussion period, so I'll expect
something to come now. So I am going to
bring up our panelists, and we're going to have a chance to dig in a little bit
about technologies. So we're going to have a discussion on perspectives of
evolving technologies to meet research needs.
And, yeah. Thank you. Mary Goldman from UC Santa Cruz,
Andrew Eady from Oregon Health & Science University, and Kelly Crotty
representing the NCI.
So I'll start with a few questions, but again, I'm going to need you all in the
room to carry the rest of this session forward.
So I'll get us going, but please jump in at any time.
So to get us started, I'd love to hear...
Let's start with our technology developers.
If you could just quickly introduce yourselves, what projects
you support, what your role is on those projects, and what the
technologies that you do,
what they're doing for cancer research. So let's start with you, Andrew.
Okay. Yeah. I'm Andrew Eady. I'm a professor at Oregon Health & Science
University, and my whole career has been really devoted to technology
development.
And we do a lot of work in the genomics space,
and a lot of that has been in the single-cell genomics area.
Really developing tools to interrogate the genome
and epigenome in single cells and trying to really improve the
throughput and
the cost-effectiveness of these technologies.
And a big effort is also to make it accessible.
So you can develop a technology, and if no one can really
feasibly use it, then there's not much of a point in it.
So trying to
bridge that gap and getting into the hands of researchers to actually make it
useful.
And you've been supported by IMAT-
Yeah
... and what mechanism?
Yeah, the R33. And that was for actually taking technology where we
had some strong preliminary data and showing that it was a working technology,
but it was one of these tools that no one could do.
So the goal was to get it to the point where it was able to be done with all
off-the-shelf, easy reagents. So that was the IMAT project that
we had.
Thank you. I will jump over to Mary.
Let's hear about you and the technologies you're supporting.
Yeah. So my name's Mary Goldman. I'm with UC Santa Cruz in the Genomics
Institute there. And we're funded by
ITCR, the U24, not the sustainment, but the advanced...
Yeah, the one before that one. What, sorry?
Advanced development.
And I work on UCSC Xena.
So we are making a tool. We're trying to put
visualizations
of genomics data, a wide variety of different genomics data, both on public
data and on your own data, in the hands of people who may
not have a strong computational background.
We visualize bulk data and single-cell data now.
And if I have the permission to have a plug, I have a poster.
Mm-hmm.
So if you're interested in learning more, I have a poster on
Tuesday afternoon, section 4, board 29.
So feel free to stop on by for that. And my role on UCSC
Xena, I am a design and outreach engineer, so that's kind of an
interesting title. So
the way that I think about it is I'm really focused on the user.
So I'm doing the design of UCSC Xena.
Where are the buttons? What's the new functionality that we're going to be doing?
How are we going to make it so that it's relevant for cancer researchers today?
And then I do a lot of outreach, so I give a lot of posters and talks.
I give a lot of workshops. If you're interested in a workshop, let me know.
We're very happy to give those. And then I do things like
documentation and social media and all that kind of
stuff. So a lot of fun hats that I get to wear.
Thank you, Mary.
So you started to talk about this, Mary, and I think I'll go through the panelists
and have you all answer this. You talked about moving into the single
cell space, and would love to know more about how
Xena has evolved over time and how it has evolved as
cancer researchers evolved or as your users have had different
needs.
Yeah, totally. So we actually got started with
TCGA data. We've been working on this project for a while now-With
the UCSC Cancer Browser was the predecessor,
and
the TCGA data was really fresh. It was just coming out, and we were looking at
genomic data and clinical data side by side.
And we were starting to show it to people, and two things came up.
One was people were saying, "Oh my gosh, this is amazing.
Can I give you my data? By the way, it's not published
yet, but I just want to look at it really quick.
Could you let me do that?" And we're like, "Hmm, interesting."
And then we were also realizing that we were missing one of
the powers of the TCGA data, which is it has this really
strong multi-omic focus. It's not just looking at
copy number data or expression data.
And so we went back to the drawing board and we said, "How can we make this
tool available to everybody?" And so we
created Xena.
So it has that multi-omic
integration. We really focus on
supporting
a surprising number of data functionalities or modalities.
So, we have the mutation and the copy number and the gene expression, but we also
have things like ATAC-seq data and methylation data.
And we allow you to view that all side by side with all of your clinical data that
you're interested in as well. And then, I like to say that we eat our
own dog food at Xena in that the data hub, the way that we host
the data is the same way that we offer to users to host their own data.
So if you have data that you're interested in visualizing using the same exact
visualizations for that big public data, we make that possible
for you to do it with your own data, and it just stays on your computer.
It never goes up to a server or anything like that.
And
then as we were doing this, yeah, exactly, single-cell data was coming up.
And we're like, "Oh my gosh, this is amazing." And again, how do
we get this data into the hands of everybody?
We want everyone to be able to view this data.
And so, we just got started with, I think,
the
disassociated data, looking at U maps and 2D, 3D views of
that.
Then started going into spatial transcriptomics, spatial proteomics, and
all of that.
And then, a lot of people are sequencing, again, that data integration.
People are taking data from single-cell RNA-seq, putting it on
a spatial visium and that sort of thing.
And so being able to support that type of data as well has been a
really big focus for us. So yeah, it's been really exciting.
It's
really fun working in this field. Cancer research is going at
the very, very fast pace, and so it's always fun.
There's always something new.
Thanks, Mary. And I think that's such a great representation of the flexibility.
This new thing, let's figure this out, this new need, and I think
that's a really great sign of technology that can evolve like that.
Andrew, I'd love to hear more about your perspectives on this, too.
Yeah,
moving into single cell. When I started my
lab, it was in the very early era of single cell, and we started
building a lot of tools and technologies.
And at the time, there were a lot of properties we wanted to be
able to look at the single-cell level.
And it was a really exciting time because we could figure out a
way to look at, for example, the initial early
days of single-cell ATAC-seq. And it was cool because
you're the first person ever seeing single-cell ATAC-seq.
That's a pretty cool experience. And then it's
evolved over time to where we can
generally look at most of the omics properties that
we want to look at in single cells now.
So it's shifted towards, okay, well, what are the ones that we want to pair
together for single-cell multi-omic technologies?
So we're doing some of that, but I think that the question has shifted a lot
towards really thinking about what are the ones that make the most sense for the
biology. Often it was that
we wanted to look at all these things, but the technology was limiting in terms of
what we could even try to address. And so you could only do the
things that were technologically viable.
But we don't really have those same constraints in the way that we used to.
So I think we can really start to think deeply about
the types of data that we've generated and where we can move from where we're at
now and being really smart about the types of modalities and things that
we target to really generate the most meaningful
information in terms of the biological system that you're studying.
So that's been a fun transition in terms of how the field's
evolved.
Thank you. I love that excitement for we're doing this, and we're moving into this.
Yeah.
That's great. And so you heard Kelly present on IMAT, but she's in
this really great position in that she is a leader for both
IMAT and ITCR. So I'd love to hear if you have any high-level
thoughts or trends on what you're seeing and how technologies
might be changing.
Yeah. So IMAT is one of the longest-standing programs at NCI, and
back in the late '90s when the program started, we were supporting projects
like
beadchip and bead array from Illumina and rolling circle
amplification and cold PCR, and just seeing the evolution of
technologies over the last several years.
Moving to single cell, and not just moving to single cell, but adding all of
these dimensions. Can we have a temporal dimension and look at clonal
analysis over time and tumor evolution and the spatial
dimension, looking at spatial omics and not just
transcriptomics, but can we do
single-cell proteomics? Can we do single-cell genomics and proteomics in the
same cell? And it gets more complicated as we
develop these
more sophisticated experimental technologies.
We also have to create better sample preparation and sample
analysis methods. So, can we do a single-cell analysis on
FFPE tissue or something like that, where it's so much harder to dissociate
those cells? And it's been really exciting to see how this grows.
And of course, with ITCR, we need a way to integrate all of these
different dimensions of data. I think that for ITCR, I can't
even touch on how things have evolved since
You know, kind of the AI boom over the last several years and the number of machine
learning applications that we get recently.
Something that I find really exciting is
how we're tackling issues of patient privacy, because there's so much data out
there,
it's so rich. There's so much that we could learn, but
there's these data-sharing constraints, of course, because we need to protect the
patients. And so, things like federated learning and
other things like that, as we're trying to figure out how can we make the most
out of all of this data while protecting the people that we're really trying to
help here.
Thank you, Kelly. And I think I may go back to you for
this next question, and then go into our
investigators. So I think you probably see this in the portfolio a
lot, of this balance between this is really innovative
or this is going to get in the hands of people and be adopted, or maybe it's an
and, it's not always an or. But how do you see those trade-offs,
and how do you think about that in a grant portfolio?
Yeah. So we see this in the review panel a lot, where somebody
might say, "This is a really cool technology.
I just don't see anyone ever being able to use it
because you need a really sophisticated piece of equipment," or, "You need
a really highly trained staff," or, "Most people
just aren't going to be able to get this type of sample to do this type of
analysis."
For the IMAP program,
I think the balance shifts depending on which mechanism you look at.
The R61 go for the innovation and do something
really interesting and new. And for the R33, we'll have more of an
emphasis on
not just is this interesting, but is it usable by your end
user?
I think ITCR especially, the U24 is focused
on more advanced development and sustainment of technologies that already have a
user base. That usability is a huge
emphasis on the program as well.
Thank you. And Mary, I'd love to hear your take on that, how you're
balancing innovation and usability.
Yeah. And I think I'm actually going to kind of echo a little bit of what you said,
Kelly, which is that I think really in
this day and age, it's innovative to be usable.
How many tools are out there that are created,
and GitHub repositories just languishing that maybe a
couple people use, maybe a lab, maybe a couple labs, but
it doesn't have that wide adoption.
It doesn't have that wide usability.
I
think a lot of that is because there's not the incentive structure for
it, right? It's like these tools are being created by grad
students. They're being created by post-docs. They need to publish.
They need to advance. They need to get out. Right?
At no point in there is an incentive for them to create a tool that is
usable. And so I think that's why it's been
really great to have the ITCR program with its focus on usability,
right? Creating a tool that's going to have a wide impact
across the scientific community,
not just a little couple of people here and there.
And I think one of the interesting things too, or interesting things that ITCR
focuses on is interoperability as well, right, which is
another part of usability. Right?
So not only
people can come to Xena, you can look at something, and then you can click out to
another tool, or other people click into us, right?
So you're creating an ecosystem of tools that are all connected to
each other, and it makes it possible for users to be able to see
different visualizations, analyses, and that sort of thing.
So yeah, it's been really great to have the ITCR funding to be able to focus on
that.
We didn't even pay her anything to plug these programs like this.
What about you, Andrew?
Yeah. I completely agree, and I think
the usability is so important, especially with software and things like
visualization.
It's so critical. You look at so many papers, and they're using these tools, and
the ones that are used the most are the ones that are the most usable, and
can do the visualization because that's where you can get it into the hands of
someone who knows the biology. We do this with all the single-cell data and
everything that we're generating.
It's great, but we collaborate with a lot of people that are biologists, and then
they need a way to actually dig into their data, and they're the best person to
do it because they know the biology, right?
So tools that can actually get the biologists to
be digging into the data and interpreting it is really important.
That requires visualization. And having the incentive structure that
ITCR has is great.
One of the challenges, though, is there's funding for it, but
the publication space, I think, is where that's lacking.
If you develop a tool where it's extremely usable and really
powerful,
but it doesn't have some flashy new algorithm, then journals are less
likely to be interested in it. And I think that's a problem.
I think that's something that really needs to be addressed because
the usability of it is so important.
And same with the molecular technologies as well.
You look at a lot of the technologies,
including the stuff that I developed for my lab, the first versions are always
completely unusable by anyone but us,
just to be totally honest, because it's really challenging.
We're putting out these new technologies, and we're very clear that this is the
initial proof of principle of this technology.
This is where we're able to get this to work.
Yes, it's a 16-hour protocol with no stopping points, and half the time
it doesn't work at all, but it's proof of principle, and it can produce
amazing data.
And that's the paper that gets in the big journal, and then the one where we're
like, "Oh, we did a ton of optimization.
Now it's a robust protocol with a stopping point every hour, and we haven't
had a failed experiment yet." And it's like, okay, well, people aren't as
interested in that. So I think there's a
real strong need for the publication space for wanting to
I'm going to jump in here because I care a lot about this topic, and
I think that the incentive structure is not
incentivizing these sorts of activities of getting other people to use your
technology. And it's not just the students and the post-docs who
want to publish and then get their next position, but the
professors. How are you going to be promoted, right?
Somebody looks at how many grants did you get, how many publications did you get,
and they're not looking at a metric of how many people are using your
technology. And you could have a huge impact on research by making
100 labs are now running your experiment and doing it faster or more
accurately, but that's not feeding back into any benefit
for the PI or for the lab, and so that's really challenging.
And so I think on multiple levels, the incentive structure needs to be reimagined.
And
we see in terms of innovation, this is really challenging in the review.
If you're proposing, "I'm going to collaborate with these labs, and they're going
to do some independent validation," where's the innovation, right?
Mm-hmm.
They're just repeating the experiments that you've already done.
And so the reviewers struggle to feel excitement about it because there's no
innovation per se. But for IMAT, we see it all the
time. These experimental technologies, the project was successful.
They developed their tool, and then it went nowhere.
Nobody ended up using it, and it's because there's
very little incentive to do that next step, even though that's where the
impact is. It's not just building what you can but getting people to use it.
Thank you. Yes. Incentives, credit, lots of restructuring that
we may all need. And nice that we have these technology-centric programs where
that is recognized, but much harder to play in the broader NIH
landscape with those. So I have a last question, which is
a reminder to all to get your questions ready.
So just to think, looking into the future for the people in
this audience who might be wanting to develop technologies, do
you have recommendations so that they can be developing technologies that
are going to stay relevant and have long-term
impact? So maybe start with you, Andrew.
And I think you were starting to really get into that with your last answer of
thinking about usability. Yeah. I think
as a technologist, I get excited about cool molecular techniques.
And often trainees in my lab are excited about things, and they're like, "Oh, I
want to go off on this technology" that they're really excited about.
And I think often I have to pull them back, and you always have to ground it in the
specific biological question and
what it's going to address.
All the stuff that Kelly was saying about
what those grants need to have, you need to really think about all those things
before you even start the process of developing a technology.
And I wasn't as good about that earlier in my career.
I was like, "Ooh, shiny technologies.
Let's explore these things." But now every time, every technology we want to
pursue is very grounded in exactly those questions and
making sure that we have an idea of what the
arc of the technology is going to be from that early conception to--
It's going to be this initial technology that's probably not going to be usable,
but we do have an idea of how we could eventually get it to something that's
usable. And then from there, how could
that then lead to other technologies from that,
and keep expanding. So, yeah, that's the process
that I've learned has worked the best, and just
really doing that due diligence upfront in terms of planning kind of that
technology arc
from the get-go.
Thank you. And Mary, I think you've touched on this question a lot, too.
Any additional thoughts?
Yeah. I have two recommendations for
keeping your tool relevant and everything like that.
The first one is kind of echoing what Andrew said is,
you need to talk to your users.
You're not just imagining your users, you're actually talking to
them. Because you might think that you're creating something that's really usable,
but your users have a different experience. They have different difficulties.
They have different ideas. And so something that might sound like,
"Oh, this is just going to make them-- They're going to love this." And then it
turns out, actually, it wasn't, because you didn't actually talk to them.
And I think that you need to talk to people
early on in the process. Again, this is what you're saying, Andrew.
Usability is not like a varnish you put on
at the end. You're like, "Oh, now it's usable because I talked to people at the
end." You need to talk to people at the beginning, make sure that it's fitting
into their workflow, their needs, everything like that.
And then if I might make a slightly specific thing, is that when you
first start talking to your users, don't actually pitch your
tool right away. Don't pitch your idea because
people are nice. And so if you say, "Oh my gosh, I have the new thing, you're going
to love it," they'll say, "Oh, that sounds great.
Yeah, I'll totally use that." So really talk to them
before. You can pitch your tool eventually, but don't start off with telling them
how amazing your tool is and everything like that.
So that's my first recommendation.
And my second recommendation, which
might be a little bit surprising, is to have good documentation
which all the developers in the room are groaning right now.
Yeah, nobody likes to do it, but having a tool that is well documented is
going to make it a lot easier for people to be able to use it.
And we live in a time of AI.
Large language models. How are the
AI agents going to be able to find your tool, to recommend
your tool to someone else, to be able to use your APIs to do data
analysis, to make visualizations?
AI is going to read your documentation, and so
having documentation, just to start out with
and having good documentation is really going to make you relevant going
forward in this time of AI.
What about you, Kelly? Any last thoughts on this topic?
Yeah. So imagining that you're at the point where you've maybe developed a
technology, you've got it working in your own lab, and you're thinking
about that next step of other people starting to use it.
Connecting with your end users is the number one thing to think
about. At NIH, we have a number of programs that can help you do that.
C3i is a program where you are paired with a
project manager and a business advisor who talk to you about your
technology and whether you might have a market.
You do a number of interviews with your end users, where you're not being a
salesperson, you're not pitching your new technology, but you're trying to
learn from them, and then incorporate that learning
into the design of your technology.
And there's also the I-Corps program, as well as the Entrepreneurship Bootcamp,
which again, have a huge component around having interviews with people who
might be your end users. And a lot of people who go through these
programs, they came in saying, "I have a
new technology for early detection of breast cancer." And after talking
with the end user, they're like, "This device would be better used
for disease monitoring of lung cancer.
It's the same device, but I wasn't actually filling a
need. I talked to the end users, and nobody cares about that sort of
technology." And almost everybody ends up pivoting by
finding a more useful niche, something that would actually address
needs. And so that's huge.
Once you've connected with your end user, finding a small group of people who
work in your field, who might be early adopters, and reaching out to
them and trying to get them to just do the experiment in their
lab.
So a lot of people, especially in academia, think, "My publication is
it. I created the method. I published it. That protocol is out there.
People will start using it." And that is completely not true.
We've had funding opportunities incentivizing people
to take new technologies and try them out in their lab.
Thousands of people were eligible to apply, and we got
dozens of applications. And not for a lack of
trying and advertisement. So there's a huge activation energy for a
lab to use a new technology because there might be a
lapse in productivity as people try and train, and
learn, and troubleshoot the new technology.
They have to question sustainment.
Are you going to continue to update this technology over time?
And they have to recognize, is your technology actually going to make
my research better or faster or more reliable?
What about all the other technologies out there?
And if I adopt your technology, is it going to be deprecated in a year, and
something new and shiny is going to come along?
And so actively reaching out to those people who might use it, and
then making it easy for them to use it, creating a toolkit of
all of the custom reagents or custom fabricated hardware that they
might need to run the experiment, giving them the updated protocols and the
documentations that they would be able to use it, and then collect
feedback afterwards. Get them to do the experiment, and then ask them,
"How did it go? Did you replicate my experiment?
Did you find this easy to use? Did it work with your
workflow?" And then incorporate that feedback into the
design of your experiment. And hopefully, you'll get some of those early adopters
who are willing to collaborate with you to publish on it and say, "I used that
person's method, and it worked really well." And getting those other people, those
independent labs, to publish on your method also, is starting
to have a ripple effect, where then it's going to have a broader reach, and even
more people will start to recognize this as a reliable,
usable, useful technology that they might want to use for
their research as well.
Oh, thank you three very much. So that was my last question.
Ready for any from the audience.
Oh, fantastic.
Hi, Michelle and Kelly. Thank you so much.
I was lucky to get funded for ITCR for long, two
years, two round. So I have question about this new RFA.
You have two U24. I notice the budget previously,
the substantial is unlimited up to, but now they all become
600 same. My first question is, at the end of the day, if that
two U24 will compete at the same slot,
or they just compete separate number.
So practically, historically, which will have higher successful
rate? For example, the other ones maybe have 10%, the other
2%. I just want to see. The other thing is that, the one
development more of this new algorithm innovation, but the
substantial impact U24 sort of less emphasis on the
innovation side. I just want to see your opinion.
Yeah. So I'll take your U24 question first, and I think you're
hitting at one of the big challenges with technology development, and that's the
sustainment. And so I think we're critically thinking about that
portfolio balance of how you sustain these
high-impact, widely used tools, but you still have your pipeline to bring in the
new tools. So that funding cap was meant to ensure we can
keep that portfolio diverse and bring them all in.
In terms of directly competing with each other, I wouldn't
think of that. I'd really think of, what is the best fit for my technology?
What stage am I at? Versus how will they compete?
Because we're thinking of ITCR holistically.
We're probably not going to have a portfolio of all sustainment or all U01s,
but,
yeah, choose the best fit for your technology.
And then I think you were asking about the R21s and that early
innovation pipeline. Is that-
No, I mean, is this for the advanced environment still need to a
certain new algorithm component?
I assume that a substantial impact U24, you don't need to involve
the new algorithm, new innovation part. Is that it?
Oh, so for the sustainment?
Yeah, for sustainment.
Yeah. So I think the focus really there is to make
sure it's staying relevant.
Okay.
So if there's a new data modality that you're not integrating, then
that's going to make it harder to be sustained.
Okay.
But keeping the tool functional and
available for use by users, keeping it maintained is the big
focus, but while looking to the science and making sure it still has the
capabilities that those end users need. But yeah, it's different.
You're not going to look for a high-risk, innovative new thing there.
No, I think that's gone.
Yeah, exactly.
My understanding is
for that two U24, the other ones, you still can incorporate
such new algorithm, new data type, right?
Absolutely. Yeah. Hopefully, you need to build in some additional new
capability into that advanced development.
Yeah. Thank you.
Oh, wow. Fantastic. Thank you all so much.
This was absolutely phenomenal. So I'm actually new to
this program, and I just have a few questions, and one mainly
just piggybacking on that last one, as I'm trying to understand sort of
the timeline and the process for the
ICTR program for software development, things like that, and
programs that will be sustainable.
And so that last part, the sustainability in terms of
funding.
Is there a certain period where...
For example, Bioconductor has been around for quite some time. We all use it.
Is that a continuous funded
program? Because at some point, you're going to need your software engineers and
people like that to maintain it. And so is there funding
built into that to do that?
Yeah. So anything that's getting that sustained U24 support-
Mm-hmm
... they're continuously competing.
Okay.
So when their award is finished, they're competing for the next one.
And so to do that successfully-
Mm-hmm
... they need to demonstrate they still have the same big impact, they
have that large user base-
Got it
... and that they are staying relevant, that they haven't just kept the
tool static, but it's maybe interoperating with
different tools or capabilities. Yeah.
But the sustainment part's really hard-
Mm-hmm
... but they still have to compete at the same level as the others to make sure
it's still something that we need in the portfolio, and that it competes with the
others, and that something else hasn't surpassed it during the time.
So that's interesting. So what percentage of your programs
do have that
long life cycle versus, they all of a sudden very
quickly come out of relevance?
Oh, yeah. That's a good question. I don't know.
And Kelly, you may-
Because technology moves so fast, especially in the software world.
Yeah. I think Mary and Xena is a good
example. So Xena is there, but Xena has made
tremendous changes throughout its life cycle, and so
it's still fitting in as a high-value, high-need tool.
I think there are tools that have come on for different technologies that we just
may not use as much or technologies that there really
has been one that has become the main user
tool, the friendly tool, the tool that more people are using.
And so that one may phase out.
Mm-hmm.
So there is an ebb and flow-
Okay
... to the tools.
Got it. Thank you so much.
Great presentation. And I apologize, I missed the very
beginning. But
my question is about the
relationship of the grants mentioned to the
SBIR funding mechanism.
And is this
something that a startup can apply for
in parallel to an SBIR grant submission, or is it
really one or the other? Or are they kind of overlapping in terms of funding?
So I think both, depending on what you're
looking to do. So certainly small businesses could
be applicable here. The challenge with ITCR is that open
source free for biomedical research community.
Right.
So that has to fit your model, that the commercialization
still enables that open source. But that's
really you're developing your tools in ITCR, while the
SBIR is you're commercializing a tool that you have.
So I think they can be complementary.
Is that also true for the, is it IMAP?
The-
Yeah.
Is that something that can end up being commercialized, or does that
become public?
Yeah. So small businesses and large for-profit companies are
eligible to apply for IMAT.
The program usually supports technology development at earlier stages
than SBIR-
Okay
... might come in. For an SBIR grant, you typically have to make an argument that
there's a market for this. Right? There's market viability for your technology.
Yeah.
And IMAT doesn't require that. You just have to be proposing something that would
be useful to the research community.
You can submit to both IMAT and SBIR as long as the aims
are not overlapping within the same review cycle.
But we have supported
companies. We supported Illumina.
Every year, we've supported a couple of companies, both large and
small.
Great. Thank you.
We just had to get you all warmed up.
Sorry. Just following up on his question.
For ITCR, there's a lot of open source models, right?
That a company goes and backs it after as a maintainer of it and then
has tools or dashboards or something on top of the open source.
Is that something where a company could come in and say, "Yes, I'll provide
this open source, but the actual company's going to be based on this other thing
that uses that?"
Yeah. They'll have dual models.
Is that a model?
You just have to maintain-
Okay
... that open source for the biomedical and nonprofit research community.
Yeah.
But there can definitely be the commercialization arm that supports that.
On top of it for a company.
We have tools that are split in that model.
Okay. Great. All right. Thanks.
All right. Thank you all so much for being here today.
And again, please follow up with us if you're considering these and want to ask
specific questions on your technology. Thank you.
Thank you.